こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーと
…………
wwwwww
はい、皆さんこんばんは
今の時刻はですね
うぉ、お、お、お、やばいやばいやばい!!!
ただいま四時四十四分になっております
で、我々三人は今から寝るんですけども
俺は考えた
お前たち、朝は強いか?
弱ーい➡
⇦弱い
いや、そこは強いって言ってくれないと
企画的におかしくなっちゃうから
⇦めっちゃ強いよ➡
そう、僕も強いのですけども
この、寝起きの強い俺たちで
今日は誰が一番寝起きが強いかていうのをね
ちょっと、科学的に
...............
普通に誰が起きるのが一番強いか
寝起きが強いのかというのをちょっと
バトルしようと思います
簡単なやり方です
ビーチフラッグって分かります?
砂浜があって
よーい、バンで二人がバッと起き上がって
先にフラッグの所まで行って取った方が勝ちというルール
僕は
寝起きビーチフラッグというやつを今日はやってみようと思います
あーのすごい、なんだろ
別に、そんなに面白くないよ...
wwwwww
純粋に
俺の
ね、寝起きの強さを
見せたいからみんなに
はじめん強いもんね
寝起き最強
寝起き最強だね
テンプルにアラームをかけます今から
スマホでアラームをかけて
ちょうど三時間後に設定して
三時間後にタイマーがなって
誰が寝起きで一番そのタイマーをすぐ止めれるか、というゲームです
まぁ至ってシンプルなんですけど
絶対俺には勝てないから寝起きの早さは
wwwwww
もー、何が何でも次勝つんで
というわけで ちょっと
寝起きビーチフラッグをやってみようと思います
じゃ、おやすみなさい
では
今四時五十分なので
じゃあ七時五十分か
七時五十分に設定します
この時間に
アラームがなるので
それをちゃんと止めれば勝ちです
ではアラームかかりました
丁度スタートでございまーす
おやすみ
ホントに多分日本で、日本有数の速さだよ
フッフン！
(アラーム音)
おっしゃあ!
くそ
勝ったぁ!!
勝ったああぁぁああ!!!
っしぃぃぃぃぃいいい!!!
てってれれれれれてってれれれれれーーー(音楽)